- I'M A TEENAGE BEER WOLF!
[howling]
- WHOA.
- OH!
- I'M DOWN. [howls]
- BEER WOLF DOWN!
- WHO IS READY FOR A NIGHT
AT THE MUSEUM OF TOLERANCE
OF ALCOHOL?
I AM.
- OH, JILLIAN!
TURN THAT SONG UP!
- OH!
- TURN THE BEAT UP.
UH, UH, UH, UH, UH.
- YES!
- GUYS, NO! NO.
SHE'S MY BABY.
- SHOOT THE WIPER FLUID!
SHOOT THE WIPER FLUID!
- YEAH!
- OH, OH!
- THAT'S COOL.
YOU SEE EVERYONE'S TECHNIQUE.
- YES, THANK YOU.
- JILLIAN, GREAT IDEA
FOR A PARTY.
YOU BROUGHT
YOUR SCALP COLLECTION.
- UGH.
- NO. NO, BLAKE.
THEY'RE MY COSTUMES.
I'M TAKING AN IMPROV CLASS.
I THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE
THE PERFECT PLACE
TO START AUDITIONING
SOME OF MY CHARACTERS.
- I SHOULD BE AN ACTOR.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY
I LOOK LIKE MATT DAMON...
'S HIS UGLY YOUNGER BROTHER,
PHILIP--
JUST MORE JOWLS.
- I CAN SEE THAT.
- A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW ABOUT HIM.
- PEOPLE SAY I LOOK
LIKE WEIRD AL SOMETIMES...
- YEAH?
- LIKE, HIS SON.
- OH, WAIT.
I FORGOT THE BEER.
- OH.
[tires screech]
- OH!
HEY, BUDDY.
- ARE YOU LOOKING
FOR MR. WALKER'S POOL PARTY?
- YEAH.
- YEAH, WE'RE JUST GOING UP.
- RIGHT. IT'S GONNA BE
NEXT DOOR IN OUR COMMUNITY POOL.
- OOH. INTERESTING.
- REALLY?
OH, HE'S A TRICKSTER.
- OKAY.
- HE'S A TRICKSTER.
- THANKS A LOT.
- HEY, GUYS,
I NEED YOU TO BEHAVE YOURSELVES,
FOR REAL.
- AH.
GOOD CALL.
I'LL THROW THIS ONE AWAY
RIGHT NOW.
- YEAH.
- THANK YOU.
- ROCK A JOCK,
TEN-POINT SHOT!
- GET IT!
- HEY, OH!
[glass shatters]
- OH!
I AM SORRY ABOUT THAT.
[chuckles]
DAN CORTESE
WOULD'VE MADE THAT.
HE WOULD'VE MADE THAT ONE.
- I HATE PUNKS.